find the general indefinite integral and
so we have the integral of 2x dx
which of the graphs shown below
which of the graphs below shows several
members of the family
so if we're talking about so if we're
taking the integral of 2
x
dx we're talking about the
antiderivative of 2x and what's that
going to be
well it's going to be
2
x to the second power because this was
2x to the first power so we increment
the exponent to 2 and then we divide by
that newly incremented exponent so this
is going to be
x squared and you might have done that
on your own you said okay i know that
the derivative of x squared is 2x so the
antiderivative of 2x is x squared
but we aren't quite done yet
because remember this isn't the only
antiderivative of this we could add any
constant here
if we add some constant here we take the
derivative of it we still get 2x because
the derivative of a constant with
respect to x it's not changing with
respect to x so its derivative is zero
so the antiderivatives i guess you could
say here take this form
take the form of x squared plus c now
what does that mean visually
so
let's let me draw i can draw a neater
version of that so
slightly better
so if that's my y-axis
and this is my x-axis
we know what y equals x-squared looks
like y equals x squared looks like
i'll just draw the general shape
so y equals x squared
looks like this
now what happens
if i add if i add a c let's say if i add
let's say y is equal to x squared plus 2
and 2 is a valid c so we could say so
i'm going to write this down
this right over here is y is equal to x
squared but remember and i guess you
could say that in this case our c is
zero
but what if our c was some positive
value so let's say it is
y
is equal to x squared
plus i don't know y is equal to x
squared plus five
well then we're going to have a
y-intercept here at five so essentially
we're just going to shift up the graph
by our constant right over here which is
positive five so we shift up
by positive 5 and we will get something
that looks like this we just shifted it
up
now you might be saying okay well that
kind of looks like this choice right
over here but this choice
also
also has some choices
that start down here i thought we're
adding a constant but you remember this
constant can be any constant it could be
a negative value so in this case c is 5
in this case c is 0 but c could also be
negative 5.
so c could also be negative 5. so if we
wanted to do y is equal to x squared
plus
negative 5 which is really x squared
minus 5 then the graph
then the graph would look like this it
would shift x squared down
down
by five so this one is shifted up by
five this one is shifted down by five so
you would shift by the constant if it's
a positive constant you're going up if
it's a negative constant you are going
down so b
is definitely the the the class of
solutions to this indefinite integral
you take any any of the functions that
are represented by these graphs
you take their derivative you're going
to get 2x another way to think about it
the anti-derivative of this or the the
integral the indefinite integral of 2x
dx is going to be x squared plus c which
would be represented by things that look
like
so essentially things
essentially y equals x squared shifted
up or down so i could keep drawing over
and over again